project Veritas is suing James O'Keefe
and his new company and uh it's a crazy
story I think it's a death now for
project Veritas as an organization going
after James in this way but we do have
major breaking news related to this uh
we have right now uh apparently a
resignation letter from one of the
executives at Veritas I don't know if
this is related to the lawsuit against
James but I believe it likely is
because I I have to say this is for
project Veritas to sue James is
basically them saying we are done we're
over and whatever Good Will whatever
good faith you know people may have had
in us after James left is completely
gone so we're going to go over that and
uh of course we have James here to talk
about that and more and then I I think
that'll be a heavy portion of this show
because we're gonna be getting into a
lot of that story with James here but we
do have other stories about Bud Light
being knocked off the top spot it is no
longer the number one beer in this
country Modelo is